bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous alors
on a vu un des manifestants qui ont
planté un millier de croix blanches dans
la capitale brasilia
hier sur l'esplanade des ministères est
ce que clairement on est dans un
tournant dans la crise les brésiliens
disent stop alors président une partie
d'entre eux oui le problème c'est qu'il
ya encore environ un tiers qui sont
derrière lui et qui refuse de changer
d'opinion et donc le pays est très
polarisée ce qui était inhabituel dans
son histoire blé ya vraiment des gens
qui continuent à le soutenir il ya mais
lui aussi militant le sujet une
manifestation contre lui à sao paulo
mais il y en a eu pour lui à brasilia un
tout petit nombre de gens devant le
quartier général de l'armée et demandant
une intervention militaire donc on a des
gens des deux côtés et le pays vraiment
elle a eu à dire c'est vrai que vu de
france
vous allez nous expliquer ce qui se
passe parce que de fond ça paraît
ahurissant 57 mille morts avec un
président qui sont minimisés le virus
ont des consignes alors que voilà on
enterre des gens partout comment et
pourquoi le président valls hoarau
trouve encore des partisans
voyez une partie des gens qui sous de
même avis que lui que c'était bien mieux
du temps de la dictature militaire lundi
vraiment des gens très très
réactionnaire et puis y ait des gens qui
ont voté pour lui par rejet du président
du précédent régime de parti des
travailleurs et qui ne veulent pas le
maître qu'ils ont fait une erreur donc
ils soutiennent contre vents et marées
que le président a raison même si ça
défie toute opinion faut aussi se
rappeler qu'on parle d'un pays 200
millions d'habitants de 16 fois plus
grand que la france et il ya des
situations très différentes les unes des
autres
une des régions les plus touchées celles
amazonie parmi le nombre de cas par
millier d'habitants est très grave et
très élevé parce que les gens habitent
de feu ses proches des rivières et
circulant bateau est là l'épidémie s'est
répandue comme une traînée de poudre en
amazonie ça veut dire que finalement
c'est vrai que nous on entre toujours
les images voilà des choses qui vont pas
au brésil mais
que finalement le brésil ne ressent pas
autant qu'on peut le ressentir en france
en voyant les images cette crise du
coronavirus il ya des régions entières
où il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de cas mais
heureusement pour eux mais c'est en
train de s'étendre je suis géographe
je suis tout ça sous forme de carte et
je vois tous les jours lakhal la clape
ddk reconnu et beaucoup ne le sont pas
s'éteindre donc je crains que les gens
qui sont dans les régions pour l'instant
tranquille mais beaucoup de soucis à ce
mot france on a réussi à circonscrire à
peu près il ya des régions françaises
qui ont été très peu touché j'ai peur
que la façon dont on s'y prend au brésil
ça ne continue à s'étendre
même dans des régions jusque là
relativement tranquille alors on l'a dit
à beaucoup de pauvreté je vais
volontairement poser cette question
provocatrice est ce que finalement le
président brésilien at-il le choix est
ce qu'il aurait pu faire comme la france
qui est un pays riche confiné arrêté
l'économie pendant deux mois le temps
que la marque le pas a été fait en
grande partie dont les confinements
commencé à peu près en même temps que
nous des parents droit probablement trop
tôt parce qu'au bout de tout ce temps là
les gens m'ont vraiment assez ils ont
vraiment besoin de gagner nos vies donc
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé le
problème c'est que ça a été de façon
fait de façon un peu désordonnée
il ya des gens qui n'ont à aucun moment
respecter le confinement parce qu'il
devait gagner leur vie au jour le jour
pour se nourrir pour nourrir leurs
enfants
vous voyez des images tout à l'heure de
la zone est de sao paulo
il faut prendre conscience qu'il y à
quatre millions et demi d'habitants dans
cette ville dans cette partie de la
ville fait 20 millions d'habitants et 4
millions et j'ai de pauvres gens qui ont
plus de revenus
il faut bien qu'ils fassent quelque
chose qui circule est donc que n'ont pas
vraiment eu le choix
on sent que les relations en tout cas du
président brésilien avec l'injustice ce
temps d'ailleurs exemple anecdotique
mais qui est intéressant ce qui ne porte
pas de masque dans un lieu public
derrière bolt sonar ou est passible
d'une amende de 340 euros enfin
l'équivalent en france en europe
une façon peut-être de la part du
pouvoir judiciaire de lui rappeler que
c'est un homme comme les autres qui est
soumis aux lois du pays
oui c'est là c'est la dernière barrière
législatif a pratiquement laissé toute
tentative de résister donc c'est en fait
les juges qui sont la dernière barrière
le l'allemande dont vous parlez lui
était donnée par un juge du district
fédéral dont il est probable qu'il n'a
pas juridiction sur le président de la
république mais c'est une façon de les
rappeler à l'ordre
mais je pense que c'est inutile il fait
il fait provocation sur provocation je
pense qu'il ya aussi une tactique
délibérée depuis le premier jour son
élection d'empiler provocation sur
provocation ce qui ravit ses électeurs
comme trump le fait aux états unis et
qui a pas grand effet sur la marche des
choses à il ya un côté provocation il ya
un côté rideau de fumée
il ya un côté communication tout ça bout
à bout et donc comme ce sont des
symboles ces symboles contre symbole
merci beaucoup avait terrible docteur en
géographie et ça aura l'université de
sao paulo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl